hello there welcome back today we're
going to look at
why ai is harder than we think by
melanie mitchell
of the santa fe institute this paper
argues that the cycles of ai spring and
ai winter
come about by people making too over
confident of predictions
and then everything breaks down and
mitchell here goes into why people make
these overconfident predictions
she outlines four fallacies that
researchers make
and details them and gives some
suggestions of what can be
done better so it's a bit of a different
paper than we usually look at but i'd
still be
interested in your opinions let me know
in the comments what you think
share this video out and of course
subscribe if you're interested in
machine learning content all right
why ai is harder than we think
in the abstract here mitchell makes the
case that
since the 1950s when ai was
sort of beginning to develop there were
repeating periods of what are called
ai springs which are periods
of optimistic predictions and massive
investment
and on the other hand periods of
disappointment loss of confidence
and reduced funding which are called ai
winters and she says
even today where ai
has a number of breakthroughs the
development of long-promised
technologies
such as self-driving cars housekeeping
robots and conversational companions has
turned out to be
much harder than many people expected
and she says one reason of this is
uh our limited understanding she says
of the nature and complexity of
intelligence
itself and there are four fallacies she
describes
in common assumptions which can lead to
these overconfident
predictions so if you know anything
a little bit about the history of ai you
are aware that this there is this cycle
of these springs and winters and this
has been
the case from the very beginning and she
outlines very clearly here
that you know when for example the
the perceptron was invented people
thought oh
we're going to do all of this extremely
cool things
here claude shannon right um said i
confidently expect that within a matter
of 10 to 15 years
something will emerge from the
laboratory which is not too
far from the robot of science fiction
fame
right and marvin minsky forecasts that
within a generation the problems of
creating artificial intelligence will be
substantially
solved so this is due to the fact they
saw
real good progress in a very short
amount of time
and they just extrapolated that progress
and um that did not turn out to be
the case and then of course there was
a winter a downturn in enthusiasm after
all these promises didn't materialize
then again in the 1980s there
were more more ai systems coming up
there was
a upswing again and a disappointment
again
and then in the 1990s and 2000s
uh finally machine learning was
introduced by the way the the 1980s
the time of like expert systems so
people
first people developed the yeah the
perceptron and thought
that was um
that was the the the best and then
expert systems people thought if we just
kind of develop these rules and have
these rule solvers
and and sort of these rule searching
algorithms
then we can build ai that did not turn
out
and now in the current paradigm we are
in the machine learning paradigm
where people develop machine learning
algorithms and they think okay
that's the way to go so
she makes the case here that also this
time we might be in a period of over
confidence she says however around 2000
deep learning in which brain
inspired multi-layer neural networks are
trained from data emerged from this
backwater
from its backwater position and rose to
superstar status in
machine learning has been around since
the 1970s but recently with big data
sets and big compute
um you know we can we can scale up to a
large number of on so
of unsolved challenges and solve them
so we can do speech recognition machine
translation chatbot image recognition
game playing protein folding
and many more things and people
let's say call this ai right
in essence this is machine learning and
machine learning and ai are almost
synonymous nowadays but we shouldn't
forget that
ai is a different thing than machine
learning it's just that
many people today believe that you can
use machine learning
in order to achieve ai
and there was all at once a new round of
optimism
about the prospects of what has been
variously called
general true or human level a.i
and she goes through a little bit of
what
tech ceos say um
like co-founder of google deep mind
predicted that in 2008 that human level
here
will be passed in the mid-2020s i guess
that's soon
um mark zuckerberg declared that one of
facebook goals for the next five to ten
years
is to basically get better than human
level at all the primary human senses
vision hearing language and general
cognition
also that would be yeah very soon these
10 years come
to an end so she says in spite of all
this optimism
it didn't take long for cracks to appear
sorry
in deep learning's facade of
intelligence so
already she's she's calling it a a
facade of intelligence and not
intelligence itself
turns out like all ai systems of the
past deep learning can exhibit
brittleness
unpredictable errors when facing
situations that differ from the training
data
um she says these things are susceptible
to
shortcut learning and i've done a video
on
shortcut learning if you're interested
in that
it's a criticism of neural networks that
is well summarized here by saying
learning statistical associations in the
training data
that allow the machine to produce
correct answers but sometimes
for the wrong reasons one should add
the correct answers in the test data set
and this stems a lot from the fact of
how these data sets are generated so
maybe
there was this famous paper that where
they tried to
um detect criminality from a face
uh portrait and they just happened to
you know their assembled their data set
they took all the
criminal ones from like their mug shots
but they took all the non-criminal ones
from like linkedin
and the model could just learn who is
dressed well and who smiles
and had nothing to do with with actual
criminality and this
shortcut learning is essentially where
you say
look you know the way you construct the
data set
you might there might be something in
there
where the model learns to give you the
correct answer on your test set because
that's constructed equally
however it doesn't really learn the true
thing you want it to learn
right that is certainly certainly exists
um however that is i feel that is like a
data set
problem uh not not a problem with deep
learning itself
now humans have that right so by the way
in other words these mechanisms don't
learn the concepts we are trying to
teach them
but rather they learn shortcuts to
correct answers on the training set
and such shortcuts will not lead to good
generalizations
so if you think of humans humans do that
as well
like if you know with branding and all
like
if you ever bought a pair of nike shoes
and you didn't exactly check their
quality or evaluate
them and so like maybe some of you do
but others are just like
oh it's this brand um that you know
tells me something about
it's it's it's made like the about the
quality
of the shoes or something like this like
you know they're not the cheapest
and you know they're you know not the
cheapest manufacturer even though that
might not be true
but you attach all of this to the brand
symbol
and so essentially humans perform
shortcut learning
all the time but
you know point taken these networks are
brittle they sometimes learn the wrong
attack
they're of course they're vulnerable to
adversarial perturbations though i don't
think that's like a that's like a
an exact criticism it just means that
the networks they see the world in a
little bit a different way than we do
right and you can exploit that little
difference
in order to make them do weird things
but you know you need to
really target that it's not like that
happens by itself
the i think the big challenge here is
what
what she says next um however it seems
clear
from their non-human-like errors and
vulnerability to adversarial
perturbations
that these systems are not actually
understanding the data they process
at least not in the human sense of
understand
it's still a matter of debate in the ai
community whether such understanding can
be achieved by adding network layers
and more training data or whether
something more fundamental is missing
so a couple of comments right here this
understanding and she says this
correctly it's like
in the human sense of understanding puts
it in quotes
it's like i don't think i've met yet
anyone who can actually
tell me what understanding means
and or or suggest a rigorous test for
understanding i think walid saba
came the closest to actually you know
put saying look here if this and this
and this happens then
i claim it understands but most people
just say something like
well i'll i'll know it when i see it
right
so this seems a bit um
the sorry moving a bit of moving the
goal post
of what it means to to understand
uh but i agree most people here wouldn't
think that today's ai systems actually
understand the data in the same way
humans do
for whatever definition of understand
that is commonly used
the other point here is whether that
understanding can be achieved by
adding network layers and more training
data or whether something more
fundamental is missing
now you have to remember that
you know human intelligence however
smart it might be it
runs on hardware right it runs on
neurons
and later they the authors here make the
case for embodied con cognition
but ultimately it runs on hardware like
it's it's an it's an algorithm
implemented in hardware and in
very much you know all the same it's all
it's all neurons sure they're super
specialized in in some fashions
but ultimately you only have the
chemistry that you have
and um we know for a fact
that intelligence arises from
an algorithm on that hardware so
yes you can ask whether the current
neural networks
architectures are going to be sufficient
but
i don't i don't know what fundamental
thing here
might be missing like there might be
better approaches more efficient
approaches and so on
but ultimately the human brain is
hardware too
but yeah we could more purpose-built
let's say network architectures if we
know that something
specific is missing um
maybe it's a different structure of
network or a different type of algorithm
on the hardware we could build that in
okay so as we go on um
she is going to into her four fallacies
right now the indies and remember so
she claims that because these fallacies
exist
people make over-confident predictions
about the future
of ai and we shouldn't do that
because if we make over-confident
predictions
that means we won't meet our goals and
then
we will you know the funding will dry up
because we've set two high expectations
and then we'll go into
another ai winter which is a valid thing
to say
though at some point she also quotes
elon musk here
about you know self-driving cars and and
that they're not fully
fully self-driving i think that's that's
up here
yeah so um
elon musk 2019 promised a year from now
we'll have over
a million cars with full self-driving
software and everything
and despite attempts to redefine full
self-driving into existence
none of these predictions have come true
so so this reference here is
to a link where
the where tesla i think towards the dmv
so towards the regulators they say oh
we're actually not doing fully
self-driving
uh so i think it's a bit it's a bit
uh it's a bit it's a bit weird to
to criticize you know tesla on on that
like i'm sure no other company ever has
said
has had a different tone in messaging
when they do marketing
than when they talk to the regularities
like i'm sure that that
never happens um anywhere on the planet
except with tesla right
now that being said elon musk does over
promise all the time
on the other hand he also achieves
things that no one else achieves i i
think it drives certain people mad that
even though he's not over promising so
much he still like
achieves insane results uh just not
as insane as he promises
but i i like that it makes people mad a
bit
okay so first fallacy is
narrow intelligence is on a continuum
with general intelligence so that's the
fallacy the fallacy is thinking
that um if we develop something like
deep blue it was hailed as the first
step
of an ai revolution or gpt-3
was called a step towards general
intelligence
and the the fallacy here is that
we think that there's this this
continuum
like if we get better on individual
tasks we make progress towards
general ai the first step fallacy
um is the claim that ever
since our first work on computer
intelligence we have been inching along
a continuum
at the end of which is ai so that any
improvement in our programs
no matter how trivial counts as progress
it was like claiming that the first
monkey that climbed a tree
was making progress towards landing on
the moon
this has connections to uh like kenneth
stanley as work on on exploration
on reinforcement learning without you
know
goal goal undirected reinforcement
learning
exploration based learning um where you
can
deceive yourself by just going towards
a goal maybe you need an entirely
different approach
and i guess the the fallacy here is
to to say that whatever progress we make
you know we're going to interpret that
as or whatever
successes we have we're going to
interpret that as as a
success or as a step towards general ai
and you know honestly i
i get it i get a deep blue what is not
general ai
and i get it that with like a a min max
search
tree um and a bunch of handcrafted rules
you cannot get to general ai
however you know the principles uh are
still in use like deep blue
isn't so different from alphago um
and the the concept that you need like
an
internal search that goes to a certain
depth as a look ahead
uh in order to achieve ai
is not stupid like it is
and and the demonstration that such as
systems can beat human
at a previously unbeaten task
is i think definitely progress
towards general ai i doubt we'll find a
general ai
that does not have something that at
least resembles
uh such a module the same with gpt3
like i'm i'm fairly convinced that
uh a general ai will
have some some type of self-supervised
learning of language going on it's
and and to not call gpt3 a step
into the direction of general
intelligence like
sure it you know all the criticism it's
just interpolating training data
yada yada yada you can leverage that but
it's undeniable that that gpt-3 and
the family of models there are
tremendous progress
and i would argue progress towards
general ai i guess the more question is
how much of a progress is it like is it
halfway there or is it one percent there
in a way a monkey climbing on the moon
is
a bit of progress going towards the moon
because
they you know they see the moon and they
may want to go to the moon
uh yeah so um
i agree a little bit i don't know i
don't know how
um how how valid that is though
fallacy 2 easy things are easy and hard
things are hard so that's the fallacy
where the correct the corrected version
would actually be
easy things are hard and hard things are
easy and this
is all about arguing that we
assume that you know the hard
problems for computers are also the hard
problems for humans
so whenever we solve the hard problems
for humans we think
wow that's a you know the computer must
be super smart because only a super
smart human would
achieve such a thing for example
researchers at google deepmind in
talking about alphago's triumph
described the game of go as one of the
most challenging of domains but
correctly this paper asks challenging
for whom
for humans perhaps but as psychologist
gary marcus pointed out there are
domains including games
that while easy for humans are much more
challenging than go
for ai systems one example is charades
and this is a it's a valid criticism
that people you know fall
people fall victim to how often have you
seen someone interact
with not even an ai system but any
anything technical
and asking like why can't the stupid
computer just
you know do this like how easy is that
you know and
you you have maybe coded previously and
you recognized it
it's not that easy even though it seems
super easy to a human
um yeah so
that's correct it's a correct criticism
i do think deep learning has brought us
a lot closer here like in all of these
things where
human-ness um shines
i think deep learning especially in the
perception
domain has brought us a lot closer
though
this paper argues that there's still
this kind of notion of
common sense that isn't
yet there for machines which i also
agree
fallacy number three the lure of wishful
mnemonics
and this is a bit about um how we call
things so uh the argument is
the argument is here a major source of
simple-mindedness in ai programs is the
use of mnemonics like
understand or goal to refer to programs
and data structures
if a researcher calls the main loop of
his program
understand he is until proven innocent
merely begging the question he may
mislead a lot of people most prominently
himself what what he should do instead
is refer to the main loop as
g double o three four and see
how it can how if he can conceive itself
or anyone else that g double o three
four implements at least
some part of understanding
many instructive examples of wishful
mnemonics by ai researchers come to mind
once you see this point so this is about
how we
talk about ai systems and the the fact
that
we call we call things as
as we do they give a more recent example
here again
for deep for some reason deep mind is a
lot
so ibm watson is of course here too
deepmind
as well um you know granted they do make
a lot of claims about in
intelligence and their systems so uh so
demi's hassabis says alphago's goal
is to be the best human players not just
mimic them
david silver said we can always ask
alphago
how well it thinks it's doing during the
game it was only towards the end of the
game that alphago thought
it would win and the cursive words here
are goal
things and thought it would win
and this the the fallacy here is that we
use these words
and we sort of ascribe human
tendencies human wants human needs to
those systems
so um the the
author here argues that alphago africo
doesn't have a goal
per se right we we just say this uh
alphago doesn't
think anything about itself and um
winning doesn't mean anything to it now
i
agree that by calling
things certain names we implicitly you
know we imply
that there's something happening we
ascribe humanness
to these machines that might not exist
however i
i don't necessarily agree that alphago
for example has no goal
like you know what does it mean to have
a goal
um you know how how can you even measure
that humans have a goal
right unless you you ask someone like
what's your goal but if you can't
ask a human you observe their behavior
they seem to be acting you know to
achieve a certain result
alphago does the same like i don't see
why alphago
doesn't have a goal in in the same way
at least
you can't give me like a tangible
definition of
goal that does not include alphago
unless you
you explicitly carve it uh
such that you know alphago is excluded
but
the same with you know what how it
thinks it's during the
game it was only towards the end that
alphago thought it would win
this is a bit more dicey right because
actually alphago
isn't isn't even thinking how much it
would win
against in the current game it's
actually evaluating
um its value function against itself
right so against the sort of the best
opponent it knows
so it constantly underestimates its
chances of winning because
you know unless someone is better than
alphago um
however again you know
of course winning doesn't mean anything
to alphago
however what does you know you also
can't do this for a human like hey human
what does winning
mean um who knows right
alphago does have a concept of winning a
game of getting
positive reward like there is a clear
state in its state space that relates to
a winning game position so
again it's a valid criticism that we
shouldn't attribute humanness
to these machines however i do think a
lot of
a lot of these examples here are not
as clear right the more clear ones are
down here
you know when we have data sets and
tasks uh such as the
stanford question and answering data set
this is squad short or the
the race reading comprehension data set
the general language understanding
evaluation right glue and it's
derivative super glue
these these are named of course if you
if you work with them you know fairly
quickly that this is
if it is question answering it's a very
limited set of question answering like
it's a very specific
kind of question answering it's not the
ability to answer questions and
and you know that but you have to give
it some name right
the the thought here is that
uh to the public it might seem
that you know when when then
the press writes things as microsoft's
ai
has outperformed humans in natural
language understanding
then that might be overly that might
appear overly optimistic
which is of course true uh however the
researchers i feel
are only mildly to blame for this
um you know of course there's marketing
in research but um
i would maybe you know like there's a
high chance that in this article here it
was the journalist
that massively upped those statements to
gather more
clicks and i agree though that to the
public then it's over promising maybe
there's a politician that reads this
right directs more funding because wow
and so on
and then you get this over-promising and
disappointment cycle
then fallacy four is
intelligence is all in the brain
and this is about embodied cognition and
it we should pay more attention to
embodied cognition so the fallacy is
that intelligence is all in
the brain and she criticized here the
information processing
model of the mind and
essentially saying that there is lots of
evidence that here the assumption that
intelligence is on the brain has led to
the speculation that to achieve human
level yeah we simply need to scale up
machines
to match the brain's computing capacity
and then develop the appropriate
software for this brain matching
hardware
okay so jeff hinton is there saying you
know in the brain we have
x many connections if you know once this
is a hardware problem
um however there are
these researchers in embodied cognition
gaining steam since the mid-1970s and
they have a lot of
evidence body cognition means that the
representation of conceptual knowledge
is dependent on the body
it's multimodal not a modal symbolic or
abstract
this theory suggests that our thoughts
are grounded or
inextricably associated with perception
action emotion and that our brain and
body
work together to have cognition there is
there's a lot of evidence that you know
we work
that way our intelligence works that way
however
i so if if i have to leverage some
criticism here
i would say maybe the the maybe the
author here also
uh has a bit of a humanness fallacy
in making this argument right just
because human intelligence has those
properties
doesn't mean that that's the only way to
reach intelligence even
human level intelligence or human-like
intelligence
just because humans don't work without a
body doesn't
necessarily mean right that we can't
build intelligence
otherwise i could also say so
the argument i mean there there is there
are good arguments for this don't get me
wrong
but if you say something like look
all the intelligence we ever see is body
based like
human intelligence is the only
intelligence we know and
that is intelligence that interacts with
the body right
in acts in the world and so on
i can also i can also um
here it's not it's not at all clear so
instead what we've learned from research
and in body cognition is that human
intelligence seems to be
a strongly integrated system with
closely interconnected attributes
including emotions desires a strong
sense of selfhood and autonomy
and a common sense understanding of the
world it is not at all clear that these
attributes can be separated
i want to leave out the common sense
understanding of the world
right now and and and focus on like the
embodiment
in the same vein you can say you know
all human intelligence we've ever
encountered
uh looks something like you know like
like like this so you know there's a
brain stem
right here there's the frontal thing i
am terrible at drawing brains this is a
brain okay
brain you know all human intelligence
looks like this and you know maybe there
is the the spine
and there are the the proof the nerves
here
so this is a nervous system human
intelligence looks like this
uh why don't you know our computers
you know must also look like this
otherwise because all the intelligence
we ever see
looks like this right so
since you know it since we don't have
that
we need to build it it's not it's not
like i get it we all this intelligence
we see
is a brain and the central nervous
system and the body
doesn't mean that we need it even it
might
be that you know the evolutionary
pressure on humans given their body
made their intelligence super entangled
and the development of intelligence
dependent on having a
body but again ultimately we have to
acknowledge that intelligence is
something that's implemented in hardware
and it is the case that you know
paraplegics
have intelligence um i get it
things like things like emotions and
desires and so on they're still there
and
and they might play a role in the
development of in
intelligence but in
you know paraplegics have intelligence
but what doesn't have intelligence is
someone who who's been to the guillotine
right that there's no intelligence there
in you know the the body part um so
there's
there's fairly good evidence i'd say
that intelligence
exists independent of the body because
we can remove like every part of the
body
and still have intelligence except
the brain however
the body and embodiment might be
necessary to
efficiently develop intelligence and the
same
in my sense goes a bit for common sense
this
common sense is a bit of it's a bit of a
a mystery word that people use i feel
so common sense they mean like oh you
know the things that you just know
right but i would say you know this this
is this common sense that people mean is
the result of
ginormous years of evolution you know
built into your brain or at least making
your brain extremely adapt to learning
these things
really quickly right that's what
evolution has done
so in that way it is very much a scale
problem it's very much a data plus
scale problem and maybe some you know
clever neuromorphic algorithms or
something like this
but it's not it's not like you know we
oh we have to put in common sense it
seems like a
scale problem we could accelerate it
by you know directly programming in
common sense
but it's not the it's not like a
qualitatively
different thing at least i feel
i do agree that embodiment is
probably a good way to go in order to
develop
a general ai in order to push the next
boundary of ai especially
kind of multi-multi-modal
multi-uh sensory intelligence
and also reinforcement learning so
models that act in the world and observe
their own actions but
we have that kind of too like they're
like a recommender system
like youtube or something they do
you know the actions have influence on
the system and so on it just doesn't
handle it super well
for now so that were the four fallacies
uh she lays out a bit of a future future
plan here
uh especially you know focusing on you
know we we need to get these machines
a bit of common sense that's still
missing we attribute too much humanness
to them uh we need to go after
maybe more after embodied cognition
because that seems to be very promising
um we shouldn't use wishful mnemonics so
we shouldn't call our things something
like
maybe something like attention like we
should maybe call ours
our routines attention because you know
it's not the same kind of attention that
we call attention
um we shouldn't assume
that the same things are hard for humans
as they are for machines
and finally wait where was it we
shouldn't assume that just
any new solved task is a step towards
general
intelligence those are the four
fallacies
and that was this paper i invite you to
read it in full it's some
has some good uh stuff in what i didn't
read right now
uh go check it out tell me what you
think in the comments
and i'll see you next time bye